congratulations on the film and gal you
know you know from experience with fans
around the globe that the first wonder
woman film inspired little girl
little boy to really harness their own
superpowers wouldn't poke this film
inspired
love acceptance um i feel like we're
living in an
era that is full of criticism and full
of hate
and you know if someone has different
opinions to yours there's no tolerance i
just hope
that this movie reminds people that
we're all one
we're all the same we all suffer from
the same
problems and we all have the same wants
as cheesy as it might sound but the only
solution to bring us all together is
just
love we do need a lot of love right now
but how important was it to both of you
ladies both you gal
and to patty to both still be able to
bring fans this wonderful
you know wonder woman experience
obviously through first and foremost the
film
but then obviously through this
exceptional and fun
virtual experience as well during times
like we are in
at the moment so important we talked
about it all the time you know we were
saying okay if we're gonna go forward
and do this and release this film at
this time how can we
how can we engage with everybody and see
everybody and thank everybody and look
at people's you know
connect with our fans it's such it's
like the best part about releasing a
movie is getting that
interaction we make a movie alone you
know
all together but not getting to engage
with the audience and so
warner brothers just did a great job of
putting this together so so that i can
see your face and i can see the fans
faces and we can connect and so
we're so grateful that we get to do it
okay i gotta ask so
barbara in the film she's surprised to
learn that diana knows
latin so i'm curious patty and gal
what is a secret hidden talent that you
gals have that folks at home
might be surprised to learn we can all
work
really really well on zero amount of
of sleep yeah is that a talent
i'll tell you one thing that people
wouldn't know about this whole cast
is how great they are as people and how
generous they are to each other
and one of the funnest things about
shooting this movie is that all of the
time
when they would be doing takes with each
other they would stop and then say they
were so great and be talking about the
other person's performance
and then when they saw the film all of
most of them saw it together
and they called gal and i and everybody
was just talking about the other
person's performance
and i was like i feel so grateful to be
working with like a group of people who
are real friends and admirers but
like so generous to each other you know
what i'm ready to go
i think we can do better parachute pants
yeah um does everybody parachute now now
i got a question here from mr chris pine
chris pine are you out there mister
right here well hey there handsome great
to see your face
you're rachel oh nice to see you today
buddy now without giving away
any spoilers chris how pumped
were you to be filled in about how your
character
was being worked in to the sequel and
what is
the best part about being a part of this
wonder woman franchise
patty talked about it during the first
uh when we were making
the first one rachel and uh i was uh
super excited i love the the material i
love the project i love the character i
love the people i get to work with
so yeah i can't really tell you much
about how i come back but uh
the greatest thing about being a part of
this franchise firstly i think is
it's nice to be a part of a of um
something that gets seen by so many
people that
that has such a wonderful message i
think oftentimes
with these bigger films you know amongst
all the the
flash bang and the you know um the
revenge politics of all of it things can
get
the message can get lost and this our
foam i think really has
especially for now right now
the greatest message that any of us can
as i said before like drink up like
grandma's soup it's
love saves the day her greatest weapon
is compassion hope and kindness
and um we could all do with a great dose
of reminding ourselves of that
great superpower that we all have so i'm
i feel um blessed and very grateful to
be a part of
um a story that that communicates that
message
[Music]